هذا جزء بسيط من ازمك كبيره مساله الحبوب
هنتحدث عن ازمات قد تتعقد على مستوى
العالم في حال استمرت الحرب لفتره اطول
هناك بعض المواقف في الحقيقه في الشارع
العربي مفادها ان التعامل دوليا مع ازمه
اوكرانيا كان مختلف عن التعامل مع ازمات
في منطقتنا يعني مثلا فتح ابواب اوروبا
للجوء من اوكرانيا كان مختلفه عن فتحه
اللجوء من سوريا او من الاماكن التي عانت
من عمليات تهجير همم
كيف يمكن تفسير ذلك لشارع العربي
وبعدين انا اعتقد ان هذه النقطه واجهه
للغايه
مثل اللجنه الانقاذ الدوليه فنحن حالنا
حالكم قمنا بتصليه الضوء على مساله وجودي
معيار واحد وليس معايير مزدوجه والكيلي
بمكيالين بالنسبه لنا من سوريا او من جنوب
السودان او من اوكرانيا
او من جنوب السودان اوغندا
الى الدول
موجوده في الاردن وفي تركيا
افغانيه
ولابد ان يكون هناك ادراك عالمين لمسؤولين
لمسؤوليه التي تظهرها هذه الدول ونحن ضد
المعايير المزدوجه وانتم محقه في الاشاره
الى هذا الامر